Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO. Ja, vielen Dank an Stefan heute für das Intro, herzlich willkommen, ihr hört das Podcast UFO mit meiner Wenigkeit und mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan Tietze. Hallo Stefan, schön, dass du da bist. Ja wollte auch mein Intro einreichen, habe mich gefreut, dass es so schnell durchgegangen ist, weil ich habe es ihm anonym geschickt und jetzt wurde es heute gespielt. Das ist das wahre Zeichen für Qualität, das auch ohne, dass ich davon wusste, es nehmen würde. Das habe ich neulich gedacht, das ist so krass, neulich hätte ich so eine Popphase, habe ich so Bock gehabt auf gute alte Pop-Songs.
Und dann habe ich ein paar Songs in meiner neuen Playlist gehabt und habe dann da mal die individuell gegoogelt, von wem die denn so geschrieben sind.
Finde ich immer ganz spannend, auch weil ich gerade vielleicht so eine Musikphase habe und deswegen gerne wissen möchte, wer hat die denn überhaupt geschrieben, wem habe ich das denn überhaupt zu verdanken.
Und alle drei Songs wurden vom gleichen Typen geschrieben.
Ja?
Ja, Max Martin.
Das ist eigentlich gut, eigentlich ist das so Next Level Fandom, du bist nicht Fan von einem Interpreten, sondern Fan von einem Komponisten eigentlich. Aber ich wusste gar nicht, zu welchem Grad. Denn Max Martin hat eigentlich die ganze Popmusik, wie ich sie kenne, und eigentlich auch die Welt in den letzten 20, 25 Jahren geshaped. Und das ist unglaublich. Und dann habe ich auch erst gedacht, ah krass, wie kann das denn überhaupt sein, dass man quasi, das müsste ja eigentlich wirklich ein Zeichen für Qualität sein, dass er immer wieder Hits hat und niemand wegen eines Komponisten einen Song kauft oder eine Platte kauft oder sowas, sondern immer nur wegen den Interpreten. Und er steckt eigentlich immer dahinter, das ist ja eigentlich das Zeichen für Qualität. Dann muss man aber sagen, ja, vielleicht auch nicht, weil er durch seine frühen Erfolge arbeitet er immer auch mit den krassesten Leuten zusammen und hat deswegen ja vielleicht auch einfach mehr Erfolg. Aber er hat am Anfang fing er an mit, sein erster großer Hit war Hit Me Baby One More Time von Britney Spears. Ja. Dann hat er die ganzen Backstreet Boys Sachen gemacht, I Want It That Way und so, die ganz grossen Popsongs, die damals wirklich die Zeit geschapt haben. Dann hat er die NSYNC Sachen gemacht, dann hat er alle Songs, die ich damals total toll fand als Schüler von Kelly Clarkson, Pink, gemacht, inzwischen, also Shake It Off, dann auch wieder eine ganze Kultur geschapt, eine ganze Popkultur, I Kiss The Girl von Katy Perry hat er auch geschrieben, dann super viele Lady Gaga Songs, Adele Songs, ähm, es ist die einflussreichste Person der Welt, weil man denkt ja bei Einflussreich immer so an irgendwie Jesus oder sowas, aber es gibt ja vielleicht, vielleicht gibt es auch so eine Person, die alle Möbel designt, die wir so haben. Einflussreicher als der Papst. Jetzt haust du aber mal Sachen raus. Jetzt werden von dir auch mal ein paar Bälle in die Luft geworfen. Ich kann dir nicht schungieren. Ja, ich auch. Das fand ich so faszinierend, weil manchmal macht Popmusik was mit mir. Nicht immer, aber so Since You've Been Gone oder sowas von Kelly Clarkson oder My Life Will Suck Without You, aber auch Shake It Off oder sowas oder jetzt die Tage fand ich einen Lizzo-Song cool. Alle von ihm, alle von dem gleichen Schweden. Einfach, der wohnt in Stockholm, hat da super lange auch gewohnt, ist immer noch mal, wollte auch nicht weg. Die Schweden sind schon krass, also mit Ikea beeinflussen sie komplett einfach alle Möbel-architektur durch Musik und dann noch diese ganzen Stiglarsson-Bücher, die Schweden bestimmen, wovor wir Angst haben, was wir essen, worin wir wohnen und was wir hören. Ja, die haben, also. Die sind ganz tief drin überall. Vielleicht machen sie uns auch Angst, damit wir Popmusik hören. Ja, und damit wir uns, machen uns Angst mit Thrillern, damit wir uns in unsere Wohnung zurückziehen, wo wir dann Popmusik hören. Ich verstehe, Wahnsinn. Wo wir in unsere besser eingerichtete Wohnung ziehen wollen, um dann Popmusik zu hören. Ja, die schaffen das schon, die haben ein Gesamtkunstwerk damit erzielt. Aber da war ich wirklich sehr beeindruckt. Also, und hört mal bei Spotify, sucht mal nach der Max Martin-Playlist, die gibt es ja immer von den Künstlern, die immer so This is Max Martin und hört mal diese Playlist, das ist irre. Also für welche, er macht alle Weekend-Songs auch, also ich würde sagen, so die letzten Pop-Songs, die wirklich so dann für die Pop-Musik in dem Jahr standen, waren so Blinding Lights und vielleicht Can't Feel My Face, auch von Max Martin geschrieben. Jetzt, also Wahnsinn, ich war super beeindruckt und dachte mir, holy shit, die Schlagzeile, in der der Nummer eins jetzt raushaut, ist insane.
Das einzige, was natürlich noch zu Max-Martin-Oeuvre fehlt, ist ein Podcast-Uvo-Intro, also das fehlt ihm noch. Das fehlt ihm total. Das will, also vielleicht haben wir es auch schon bekommen, aber noch nicht, also als Max-13 oder irgendwie sowas abgeschmettert oder so, wissen wir nicht. Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe auch gerade eine Musikphase, aber eher eine negative Art, weil ich glaube, mittlerweile 90 Prozent meiner Zeit auf Spotify verbringe ich damit, einen Song zu suchen aus der Deine Playlist der Woche von letzter Woche. Das ist hauptsächlich meine Arbeit. Ich habe meine Playlist der Woche, habe da einen Song drin. Ich hatte die Lösung für dich. Und ich hatte noch nie so eine einfache Lösung für irgendein Problem, was mir irgendwer an mich herangetragen hat.
Es gab ein neu faszinierendes Gefühl für mich. Du willst jetzt sagen, mit deiner Lösung hätte ich mir die letzten Wochen sparen können, hunderte Stunden mit Suche verbringen? Ja. Eine App, die heißt If This Then That. Du kannst ganz einfache Zusammenhänge erstellen in deinem Handy dadurch. Die heißt If This Then That, I-F-T-T-T. Da machst du, und dann kannst du eingeben, alle ... Finde ich ein komischer Name, könnte man das nicht anders nennen, irgendwie zum Beispiel das Podcast-Ufo oder so. Ja, das ist nicht ein besserer Name für den App-Vorschlag. Aber diese App kannst du dir runterladen, anders als alle Apps, die das Podcast-Ufo heißen, kannst du dir die runterladen, weil die existiert. Download. Downloaden. Okay. Und dann kannst du eingeben, alle Songs, du kannst einen Algorithmus quasi kreieren, das macht das alles für dich im Hintergrund, dass alle deine Spotify Mix der Woche Songs automatisch in einer neuen Playlist, die heißt dann Mix der Woche, gespeichert werden. Ich habe jetzt eine Playlist, da sind alle meine Mix der Woche drin, seit den letzten zwei Jahren. Das ist praktisch. Auch rückwirkend, oder musst du die davor installiert haben, oder kann ich jetzt nochmal die von letzter Woche? Nein, nein, ab jetzt kannst du das. Ja, okay, gut, okay. Weil ich hatte die ganzen letzten Wochen nur zwei Hinweise, zwei Harfen, und du hast zwei Harfen in den Song gehabt? Also der Song bestand nur aus einem Harfen-Duett und der Titel war Irgendwas mit Fliegen. Du hörst die Musik, die Bösewichte, aber so Disney-Bösewichte hören. Ja, genau. Also so Dracula oder so Davy Jones. Ich habe so zwei Engel versklavt, die für mich den ganzen Tag Harfe spielen müssen. Und du wohnst in so einem grossen, schwarzen Turm, ganz alleine, mit einem
glatzköpfigen, keine
Haare am ganzen Körper, Dina.
Ja, genau, so ein Golem, hast du nicht richtig
eine Persönlichkeit? Er will,
er will, ich will dich nicht stören.
Aber ich muss jetzt schon wieder Bartholomeus.
Und du sitzt einfach nur in so einem
grossen Raum und da spielen
zwei Harfen. Ja.
Spielt für mich, ja, spielt
für mich, ja,
dieses Lied
hier mit, spielt
für mich diesen, was ihr letzte Woche
nochmal. Der ist eben
Mix der Woche? Ja,
dieses, wie hieß es nochmal,
Flying oder
so und so war ich die ganze Woche.
Nee, das ist es nicht. Das ist es nicht. Und die ganze Woche. Sir, ich stelle sie nur ungern. Was ist denn wie der Bartholomeus? Der weisse Zauberer steht vorm Schloss. Ach, was will er denn? Er will sie besuchen. Ach, er hat einen anderen Menschen dabei, einen Menschen, ein Menschling. Was? Einen Menschling, er sieht aus wie der König von vor fünften Jahren. Lass mich mal in meinen Schausteinen schauen. Ja, okay. Ach, wer wimmelt denn ab? Die ganze fucking Woche. Die ganze Woche. Das ist eine laute Hafenmusik auf deinen Sonos Five-Profon. Ich war die ganze Zeit auf YouTube unterwegs, weil Harfe ist irgendwie so ein Instrument, ich habe das Gefühl, dass danach sucht man selten. Immer wenn es gespielt wird, okay, ja, nehme ich gerne hin, aber es ist nicht so, jetzt mal eine Hafenmusik. So, und dann gehe ich da rein und wirklich, ich hatte nur Harp Fly
Song, Harp
Harp Air. Ich kenne das Problem.
Ich war so fucking verloren. So schlimm.
Ich war noch nie so verloren in meinem Leben.
Und ich habe wirklich so viele Hafenvideos, dass ich
wirklich angefangen habe, die Harfe zu hassen.
Also ich hatte wirklich in meinem Kopf
Hafenhass durchgehend,
ich hatte wirklich so diese Vorstellung, dass ich mit so einer Kneifzange so jede einzelne Seite so einzeln abschneide.
Das wäre so lustig, dann findest du diesen Song und googles den und bei Wikipedia hat er so einen eigenen Absatz über dieses Phänomen.
Ja, genau, dass sie ihn alle nicht finden.
Seit den 90ern gilt dieser Song als berüchtigt, berüchtigt dafür, dass wenn man ihn nicht mehr darauf kommt, auf den Titel Hafenhass auslöst. Ich habe es nicht mehr, es ist mehr, es ist mehr, es ist mehr, es ist mehr, es ist mehr, es ist mehr, es isturchtbar. Ich verstehe Hafen noch nicht. Ich verstehe nicht, wie die so laut sein können. Für mich ist es einfach nur, wie es ist wie so Zahnseide oder so Nylonfäden an einen schönen Bilderrahmen.
So, ne, so Formen wollen wir jetzt mal nicht reden, aber es ist in etwa so ein schöner alter Bilderrahmen, wo man einfach so oben was drangemacht hat, unten was drangemacht hat und dann gespannt hat, bis es kurz vorm Reissen ist. Und dass das Geräusch Instrumente, in die so Kunstarbeit geflossen ist, wie so in den Klangkörper alleine schon, die alle einen Resonanzraum haben, oder in die man doll reinbläst, verstehe ich, wie die die Lautstärke erzeugen können, aber wie diese Harfe so laut sein kann, will nicht in mein Köpfchen rein.
Riesig, so diese kleine Hermes-Harfe, die man so griechisch, das so eine kleine, die so groß ist, die wie so ein iPad so groß ist, das man so in der Hand halten kann.
Aber diese riesigen Harfe, vor allem, ich hätte wirklich Angst an so einem Instrument, weil ich habe ja Gitarre gespielt und mir ist einmal beim Spielen eine Seite gerissen und die hat mir in den Finger reingepeitscht und die stehen ja wirklich unter großem Druck und ich habe auch Druck, also ich habe da wirklich Stairway to Heaven, habe ich, also da war wirklich was dabei. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie deine Eltern dann so im Auto dich nach Hause fahren vom Vorspiegel und beide sotäuscht sind, weil wir während des Vorspiels Elternabende, das ist glaube ich mir rückblickend, ich glaube deswegen bin ich, du weißt wie nervös ich vor Podcasts-Sofo-Auftritten bin und wie generell, ich bin so nervös vor Live-Geschichten, Bühnen-Kram und ich glaube, das kommt daher, dass früher meine Gitarrenauftritte so traumatisch waren. Diese Elternabende, also dieses einfach nur, es ist wie so zum Schlachten gebracht werden. Das war das Schlimmste für mich. Alle Eltern der Stadt mit Kindern, die da Gitarre lernen, kommen dann da hin und setzen sich hin und die Gitarren und alle werden so nach, machen wir uns nichts vor, danach sortiert, wie gut sie sind. Ja. Weil, wie lange sie schon Gitarre haben, dann waren die Älteren halt am Ende. Ja, und du musst dich durch die anderen durchquellen. Und vor allem, du musst ja als Interpret auch die ganze Zeit dabei sitzen. Es gibt ja nicht so ein Backstage, wo man wie man im Konzert dann halt so ankommt, während das Konzert läuft, und dann tritt man mal einmal auf, macht irgendwie ein Salto oder so, und dann geht man nach Hause, sondern du musst und du denkst die ganze Zeit und vor allem dann, du visualisierst dein Instrument so, da ist der Finger, nee, da musste ich den dahin drücken und du machst dich im Kopf kaputt, weil du kriegst es nicht hin, das nochmal im Kopf durchzugehen und dann ist alles furchtbar. Und das hat so fucking wehgetan, so gepeitscht zu werden von dieser Seite, dass ich glaube, ich könnte keine Hafe mehr anfassen. Ich sag's hier und jetzt, ich könnte keine Hafe mehr anfassen. Das glaube ich dir. Ich finde, das ist kein großes Problem. Also es ist jetzt nicht, dass es dein Leben nachträglich. Du weißt doch, wie das ist in Geschichten. Am Anfang der Geschichte sagt immer jemandem, ich habe aber wahnsinnig Angst vor Schlangen. Und du weißt, in dem Film kommt noch am Ende die große Schlangengrube. Du willst mal in einem Escape Room eingesperrt sein. Ja, genau. Das moderne Abenteuer, wo du nur deine Liebgewonnene retten kannst aus dem Schlangenmeer. Wenn ich die richtige Melodie spiele. Die richtige Melodie auf der Harfe spiele. Ja, und dann hätte ich richtig Angst. Weil ich glaube, wenn da mal eine Seite reiste, also Kopf ab, einfach, batz, zack, einfach weg.
Ich habe jetzt bei TikTok das Beste entdeckt, diese Escape Rooms, aber aus der Perspektive von Leuten, die hinter der Überwachungskamera sitzen. Oh ja, ja, ja, die Foltermeister, ja. Was ist alles passiert? Idiot. Einmal wurde die ... genau, die mit dem Mikro, die haben ein Mikrofon und die können dann auch den Tipps reingeben und sowas.
Und die, da hat sich mal zwei clevere Mädels haben dann mal eine Schauspielerin eingesperrt. Die haben es irgendwie, ist es denen gelungen. Ist für mich jetzt nicht so clever, aber also. Die haben es hingekriegt, so eine Schauspielerin, so eine Geisterschauspielerin, die hat zwar so ein Horror Escape Room, die die ganze Zeit gejagt hat. Und die haben sich dann irgendwie so ganz geschickt in der Tür versteckt, die kamen rein, dann sind die beiden rausgerannt, dann haben die die Tür abgeschlossen. Und dann war dieser Geist, diese Frau, die den Geist spielt, eingeschlossen darin und sie hat mega gelacht, sie wusste, wo die Kamera ist, guckt zur Kamera und sagt, könnt ihr mich hier rausholen, weil die es ehrlich hingekriegt haben. Ach so, okay. Dann werden natürlich immer werden dann die, was ich sehr gut finde, die Feuerlösche abgemontiert von den Leuten, die in den Escape-Rooms sind, weil die es ehrlich hingekriegt haben, dann werden natürlich immer die, was ich sehr gut finde, die Feuerlöscher abmontiert von den Leuten, die in den Escape-Rooms sind, weil die halt überall nach Hinweisen suchen und alle immer diese Feuermelder abmontieren und dann drinnen nach dem geheimen Schlüssel von Barbarossa, dem Gefürchteten, suchen und dann immer diese Frau zum Mikro gehen und sagt, das ist einfach ein Feuerlöscher. Bitte montiert den wieder an, sonst müssen wir das Gebäude räumen wegen Brandschutz. Und haltet die Fluchtwege bitte frei. Das ist die deutschste Experience. Haltet die Fluchtwege bitte frei. Also keine Immersion mehr. Will uns dieses Notausgang zeichen, das da so leuchtet. Ich schalte mich mal direkt ein. Hallo, hi, ich bin eure persönliche Assistentin hier, ich bin für die Sicherheit zuständig und das ist einfach ein Notausgangsschild, dankeschön. Okay, keine geheime Tür. Bitte fasst auch nicht den Feuerlöscher oder den Rauchmelder an, danke. Und ist das Teil des Rätsels, dass sie uns versucht von... Nein, das ist nicht Teil des Rätsels. Such jetzt bitte die Schlüssel. Such die Schlüssel von Barbarossa, den Grossen. Sie sind unter der Fussmatte. Da war kein Bock mehr. Ich bin auch auf TikTok unterwegs und ich höre immer dieses ... Ich hätte gehofft, du sagst, ich bin auch oft in Escape rooms unterwegs. Nee, tatsächlich nicht. Alleine. Nee, ich höre immer nur auf TikTok dieses If you be the cash, I'll be the rubber band. Und ich habe jetzt eine ganze Woche darüber nachgedacht, aber ich verstehe es nicht. Ich verstehe nicht, was es bedeutet. Letzte Woche haben wir schon darüber gesprochen, aber ich bin immer noch verwirrt. If you be the cash, I'll be the rubber band. Aber bitte halt uns so bitte auf dem Laufenden, wenn du da weiterkommst irgendwie.
Ich finde es toll, dass dich das beschäftigt, über so einen langen Zeitraum auch. Was soll das bedeuten? I'll be the rubber band. Ja, ja, alles gut. Aber wenn du da weiterkommst, dann hilf uns bitte. Ist es so, ich bin nichts wert im Vergleich zu dir, weil das Geld ist ja mehr wert, oder halte ich dich zusammen, oder wie ist das gemeint, oder was? Bei mir waren zwei Freunde waren im Escape Room und dann hieß es am Ende so, dann lief die Uhr runter. Es war so ein Drei-Frage-Zeichen-Escape-Room und das Coole war wohl daran, es waren zwei grosse Pärchen und zwei grosse Drei-Frage-Zeichen-Fans. Die haben sich immer nicht zum Einschlafen oder so. Und das ist ganz süss. Und dann ruft halt immer Justus Jonas, ist das sein Name, ruft dann immer an, wenn die einen Hinweis brauchen oder sowas. Und irgendwie die Story, die drei Fallzeichen stehen im Stau oder sowas, kommen gerade jedenfalls zu spät da an, sind zu weit weg. Und die beiden müssen den Fall dann lösen für die drei Fragezeichen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Stau auf der B1, ich weiß nicht, ob das die... Ist sie noch im Heissluftballon gefangen? Nein, das ist einfach ein Rauchmelder. Die drei Fragezeichen stehen nicht im Stau, das ist nur ein rhetorisches Mittel, um die Story zu enhancen. Danke, danke schön. Ja, aber können die nicht eine Rettungsgasse bilden? Sie haben das Rätsel gelöst. Sie haben die Escape Room gelöst. Dankeschön. Gebt uns vorne noch eine Bewertung von eins bis fünf Sternen. Danke. Ja, und dann hieß es irgendwann so, letzter Raum und die Zeit lief die ganze Zeit runter und sie hatten noch 60 Sekunden Zeit, aber sie haben die Zeit nie gesehen. Aber es hieß dann irgendwann, ihr habt noch eine Minute Zeit. Ah ja. Und sie mussten doch diesen Schlüssel finden.
Und dann hat er gesagt, Kumpel so, ich habe kein gutes Zeitgefühl.
Aber wir haben dann noch länger als eine Minute nach diesem Schlüssel gesucht.
Deutlich, deutlich, deutlich länger als diese Minute, die wir noch Zeit haben.
Und dann irgendwann haben sie gefunden und den Raum aufgeschlossen. Dann kam sie raus und dann dann das ganze Team so yeah, ihr habt's geschafft, you did it, you did it. Und dann haben sie eine Urkunde bekommen, wo so 59 Minuten draufstehen. Aber eigentlich, also die hatten doch am Ende eine Minute Zeit und so und er meinte, also wir haben es nicht geschafft. Aber sie war das so ganz offensichtlich. Sie haben es offensichtlich nicht geschafft, aber das ganze Team stand da, hey, toll gemacht, 59 Minuten, wow. Ganz knapp, genau 59 Minuten. Aber die beiden waren sich sicher, no, no, no. Aber weil es halt so ein Drei-Frage-Zeichen in so einem Kinder-Escape-Room ist, glaube ich, lassen die immer alle gewinnen und dann 59 Minuten. Ich fand das so lustig, weil grosses Versagen auf jeden Fall, weil man 59 Minuten... Das fand ich super. Das ist schwierig. Nee, ich glaube, ich könnte das... Ich gehe nicht so gerne raus aus meiner Wohnung. Ist okay. Ich sitze gerne drin. Das heißt, im Escape Room würdest du am liebsten auch gar nicht ausbrechen? Nee, ich würde mich da hinsetzen. Geht schon mal vor. Geht schon mal vor. Du bist happy, du willst gar nicht raus. Ich will nicht raus. Übrigens, für mich war jetzt die grosse Zeit der technischen Anschaffungen. Ich habe mir natürlich die Ohrenkamera geholt, aber nach langem Ringen hin und her. Mach ich's nicht, Nasenkamera und Mundkamera. Und ein Plastiklenkrad. Ein Plastiklenkrad. Ich habe jetzt ein Plastiklenkrad, ich habe mir lange überlegt, will ich so ein Typ sein, wo man in die Wohnung reinkommt und sieht, ah, der hat ein Plastiklenkrad, der spielt gern Gran Turismo. Und ja, und ich habe mir lange überlegt, weil ich bin so ein Typ, ich bin immer sehr vorsichtig mit Anschaffungen und überlege es mir lange, aber jetzt habe ich es getan, jetzt habe ich so ein Plastiklenkrad, das klemme ich jetzt immer schön an meinen Tisch und spiele Formel 1 und es macht schon Spaß, aber ich glaube, in ein paar Wochen ist es vorbei und ich fühle mich jetzt schon schlecht und ich bin auch faul und räume das immer nicht rollen. Haben wir die Rollen getauscht? Ich glaube ja. Wirre Anschaffungen plus Formel 1, also du bist auch on the way. Du bist mein Vorbild. Der Stefan von 2018 ist mein Vorbild. Ich höre mir gerade die alten Folgen nochmal an und da fand ich dich so cool. Aus Qualitäts- und Archivzwecken. Ja, und manchmal müssen wir was Sachen finden. Sollen wir eine Qualitätssicherung eigentlich mal einführen? Qualitätssicherung. Wie meinst du, jetzt für die neunfurchziger? Ich meine, wir sind Folge 352, ich finde, wir sind gut in die 50er-50 reingekommen. Ich hätte gerne so was sehr deutsches in diesem sehr undeutschen Fun-Lava-Podcast-Projekt, hätte ich gerne einen, so einen sehr deutschen Aspekt, Qualitätssicherung und Forschung und Entwicklung. Dass wir so zwei so Studierendenjobs reinballern. Die uns darauf hinweisen, übrigens ihr wart mal besser oder so. Ja genau, folgende Folgen werden häufiger gehört als andere. Ach so.
Wenn ihr folgende Themen besprecht, bleiben die Leute besser dran.
Das finde ich gut.
Ja, macht mal wieder einen Massagesessel-Anruf.
Tja.
Ja, muss man durch.
Folge eins, das war noch auch Nachkingsbecker.
Aber das finde ich gut.
Aber seitdem, vor allem, ich habe dieses Plastiklenkrad, ich bin jetzt zu Hause, ich habe mir so ein Cockpit gebaut, weil du brauchst auch einen passenden Stuhl, habe ich nicht. Das weisst, ich habe jetzt irgendwelche alten Stühle aus dem Keller rausgerumpelt und ich bin aber auch zu faul, diese Pedale, also Pedale am Boden und ich bin immer zu faul, die wegzuräumen, wenn ich dann nicht mehr spiele. Das heisst, immer wenn ich jetzt normal eine Serie schaue oder irgendwie einfach arbeite, habe ich so Pedale unten am Tisch, die ich nie wegräume. Aber du kannst doch programmieren, dass Gas, weil das ist ja wie ein Maus, das ist ja wie Peripherie. Ja, im Grunde schon, ich kann es so programmieren. Du kannst es umbauen, dass Gas geben vorspulen ist zum Beispiel. Und es ist tatsächlich so, weil das ist manchmal ja so, wenn du so gewohnt bist, Gas geben, manchmal schaue ich ein Video und es ist mir zu langsam. Ich gebe mir Skip und ich drücke instinktiv auf Gas und denke mir, sag mal, wie fucking dumm kann man denn sein? Dann kommt so eine Sexszene und du bremst. So langsam, jetzt mal den dritten Gang runter. Ja, genau. Jetzt gehen wir mal. Bremst, bremst, bremst, stopp. Gucken wir uns an. Und das ist total bescheuert einfach, aber aktuell finde ich es noch cool. Und ich bin jetzt,weder kann ich jetzt voll all in gehen mit so einem richtigen Racingstuhl und so einem Gestell und VR-Brille und irgendwie alles möglichen oder ich steige wieder aus und komme wieder zurück. Aber ich weiss noch nicht, in welche Richtung es geht. Fantastisch. Ich bin immer noch in meiner Twitch-Rollenspiel-Phase,
wo ein Twitcher, den ich mag,
ein Rollenspiel spielt.
Es spielt das Red Dead Redemption 2 Spiel auf einem Rollenspiel-Server, wo nur ... Der Wilde Westen ist tot. Man muss den nur noch mit. Seit zwei Folgen will er den Wilden Westen tot sehen. Aber das ist nicht mehr die Realität. Das ist nicht die Realität. Ich behaupte, der Wilde Westen hat das Duell noch nicht verloren. Ich gucke das wahnsinnig gern, habe da wahnsinnig viel Spaß dran. Aber irgendwann kam es dann zu dem Moment, wo für den Streamer auch, so Inception-mäßig, das benutzt man inflationär, aber der Satz bei Inception fällt ja wirklich, wann ist dann einfach Traumen das bessere Leben. So ist es ja dann auch dabei, weil der Streamer irgendwann auch den Satz gesagt hat, warum bin ich nicht so im echten Leben? Wie er seine Rolle spielt als sein Cowboy. Er meinte, ich mag den lieber als mich inzwischen. Und es ist so spannend plötzlich, also weil der ist auch Schauspieler und er spielt da jetzt einen Cowboy, der sich am Theater für eine Rolle beworben hat, für Schauspielunterricht.
Und der dann meint dann irgendwann der Theater, der Typ, der den Theaterstel spielt, wir proben jetzt sechs Wochen lang.
Woraufhin er gesagt hat, deswegen habe ich damals Theater aufgehört, weil es so zeitintensiv wurde.
Und es ist jetzt wie, es ist so ein Meta-Experience, aber es ist so für mich jetzt plötzlich so spannend, weil es wird auch viel langweiliger gerade. Ich habe auch inzwischen nicht mehr so Lust drauf, weil es halt so ein Lebenstempo hat. Also wirklich Tempo, Speed of Life. Aber das stört mich, weil ich gucke ja etwas gerade, um meinem langweiligen Lebenstempo zu entfliehen. Dann guckt man da was, aber man stellt sich schon die Frage, jetzt auch, man macht sich ja gerne Gedanken darüber. Ist es eine Simulation, wie entflieht man denn, na Matrix und so, Das sind natürlich alles spannende Gedanken. Sind das echte Menschen, die Cowboys? Was ist, wenn die eigene Gefühle entwickeln? Sowas, ja. Weißt du, einfach. Ne, aber jetzt auf uns bezogen, man stellt sich ja schon diese Fragen ganz gern. Und dann ist es natürlich total lustig, jemanden, einen Menschen zu sehen, der wirklich so eine Simulation spielt, nur mit Schauspielern, da irgendwie durchs Leben kommt, aber jetzt an einem Punkt ist, wo er merkt, ah, ich bin schlagfertiger, ich bin besser, ich bin, und wo man sich fragt, ja, dann spielt doch eine Rolle im echten Leben und dann aber auch die Frage, machen wir das nicht eh schon. Spielst du nicht, und ich glaube, wir beide sind dann vielleicht auch krasser als er, weil ich glaube schon, dass wir manchmal, früher, bei mir ist es auf jeden Fall anders geworden, aber früher hatte ich so wenig Lust auf soziale Events zum Beispiel, auch Angst vor sozialen Events, so Introvert in mir, dass ich dann auf jeden Fall dann lieber eine Rolle gespielt habe oder sowas. Was man immer gerne Distanz hatte zu dem Geschehen und mir immer was vorgenommen hat, eine Aufgabe für den Abend oder so was oder irgendwie so ein Ding.
Oder wenn mich,
weißt du auch, man sieht, dass man fragt mich jemanden, was machst du eigentlich,
man antwortet immer anders drauf und so.
Das sind natürlich Dinge, die man im Rollenspiel viel lieber macht,
aber warum hat man da eine Distanz zu?
Weil du sprichst auch mit dem ...
Ich bin da total dabei, Distanz, Authentizität ist tot,
braucht niemand mehr, ist vorbei,
gab's nie, ist eine Illusion
von Anfang an, deswegen
weg damit, deswegen nur noch Rolle spielen. Ja, es ist Ja, auf jeden Fall ist man da wahrscheinlich glücklicher. Aber man ist vielleicht, aber vielleicht auch nicht, weil man dann nicht mehr man selber ist. Ja, ich glaube, da ist schon was dran. In früheren Gesellschaften gab es ja dann immer so Maskenball oder so, wo man gerade zu Partys eine Maske angezog hat. Was ja schon spannend ist, das macht man heute ja nicht mehr. Heute ist es ja fast... Paneball. Ja, na gut, kann man so interpretieren, ja, mit Kostüm. Aber dass man ja sagt so, ah Party, da lasse ich mal mich richtig raus, die Sau raus, da lasse ich alle Hüllen fallen und da besaufe ich mich und da bin ich richtig ich, hat man da gesagt so, nee, gerade für den gesellschaftlichen Ansatz haben alle Masken auf, weil man da vielleicht auch sich mehr traut und mehr machen kann und irgendwie, sag ich mal, extrovertierter sein kann, weil man eine Maske auf hat. Das ist, glaube ich, schon eine gute Idee, die man damals hatte, zu sagen, gerade fürs normale Leben so, aber gerade für die Party verleihen wir uns. Warum muss ich diese Maske tragen? Warum haben wir all diese Fatsuits an? Ich bin jeden Tag im Gym und so und also Joe und dann auch so Masken, weil so Joe, warum trägst du eine Maske von dir selbst? Das ist nicht die das ist nicht die Idee. Wir haben noch diese Katzen, venezianischen Katzen. Ja. Warum trägst du eine Maske von dir? Ja, weil ich sehe halt schon sehr gut aus. Und Katzen halt sehen, ich sehe halt schon besser aus als eine Katze, miau. Also es ist schon, ich bin halt schon, sorry, aber. Finde ich halt schon, ui, ui, da fällt ihm die, war noch der Flasche aus der Tasche. Aber vielleicht sollte man die Maske, das Künstliche wieder mehr in den Vordergrund rücken. Spannend, dass du Partys interpretierst als, da ist man mehr man selbst. Nee, eben nicht, ich ja nicht, aber ich glaube, die Idee ist schon so. Du hast gerade gesagt, da fallen alle Hüllen, da betrinken sich die Leute, sind sehr, wie sie sind. Das würde ich ein großes Fragezeichen hinter machen. Ich würde sagen, weil was mich immer sehr nervt, aber es ist auch, sagt man dann immer leicht und man ist aber nicht besser, aber so bei in den Clubs oder sowas, alle setzen doch immer den coolen Blick auf. Niemand lacht. Natürlich, ich würde jetzt die Idee von der tatsächlichen Ausführung unterscheiden, aber ich glaube, die Idee ist schon, in der Woche, da spiele ich eine Rolle, da bin ich irgendwie Bankkaufmann und bin immer höflich und sage nie meine echte Meinung, aber am Wochenende mit meinen Kumpels, da lasse ich so richtig die Sau raus und da bin ich ich selbst. Würde ich schon so sagen, dass das schon so die Unterscheidung ist und dass man nicht sagt, oh, ich gehe jetzt in den Club, ich verstell mich jetzt. Faktisch macht man es natürlich schon, aber von der Idee, glaube ich, ist es schon eher so gedacht. Ja, weil dann zieht man sich das Hemd an, was man die ganze Woche nicht trägt. Ja, genau. Dann da, da säuft man sich, guckt man die ganze Zeit mega cool, was man die ganze Woche nicht macht, sondern und will dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, den stark markieren. Das ist natürlich eine Konstruktion, aber die Idee ist, da sehen auch alle anders aus. So im Büro tragen alle Anzug und so, da sind alle gleich, aber im Club, da kann jeder sich selber ausleben. Es ist natürlich am Ende eine Konstruktion und alle machen das Gleiche, aber von der Idee her glaube ich schon. Aber vielleicht muss man, vielleicht müssen wir auch mehr einfach auf Maskenbälle gehen, wo man einfach diese Idee ganz... Gibt sie denn noch? Ja, keine Ahnung, oder so Lab oder sowas, wo du dann wirklich einfach so in der Rolle bist die ganze Zeit. Doch, ich habe neulich gehört, da war mal jemand auf Maskenball. Mir hat man neulich jemand abgesagt, weil er gesagt hat, nee, da bin ich mit meiner Familie auf so einem Maskenball. Und ich fand das, ich dachte, ich wäre in so einer Zeitmaschine, ich dachte, mein Auto wäre eine Zeitmaschine. Und ich wäre so in so einem, plötzlich woanders gelandet, weil mit der Ausrede, ah nee, da bin ich mit meiner Familie bei Maskenball. Ja. Da ist der jährliche Maskenball. Ja, wir gehen da zur öffentlichen Hinrichtung, da kann ich nicht. Züge, was war ich gerade? Wo bin ich in der Escape Room? Zum was? Ja, aber das ist vielleicht eine Möglichkeit. Vielleicht brauchst du mehr so diesen Lab-Charakter, da gibt es ja auch Feste und Bälle und so, da kannst du ja wirklich auch eine Rolle spielen. So, das ist ja dann die Idee, dass du dann den grossen Adligen oder Magier oder den Piraten spielst oder was auch immer, wie du willst.
Aber ich will ja gerne, aber ich will ja Kontrolle haben. Also ich will ja, ich glaube, das ist nämlich das Problem.
Ich will ja lieber dann quasi ein einfach zu überblickendes Lab, DSA, was auch immer Universum annehmen, weil ich das besser überblicken kann, da kann man bessere Entscheidungen treffen, man ist cooler, weil man auch mehr Zeit hat zum Nachdenken, was man sagt und sowas, aber dieser Lab finde ich dann wieder zu krass, weil da bist du ja wieder dann, als du selber gehst dann dahin, macht sich zwar schick und so und versteckst sich vielleicht in einem Kostüm oder einer Rolle, aber man ist wieder so sehr man selbst, also ich selbst und man ist, keine Ahnung, dann hat man da wieder so ein super unkonflikterer. Du willst schon den Avatar, du willst den Metaverse, das Metaverse, ja, rein da. Ich glaube, das wird meine Zeit, Metaverse wird meine Zeit. Das war wie für mich damals in die neue Stadt zu ziehen, als ich hierher gezogen bin, man kann wieder ein ganz neuer Mensch sein, am Ende ist man dann wieder man selbst. Aber ich, das Metaverse, das nehme ich mir vor. Ich will der coolste Mensch im Metaverse sein. Ich glaube, so schwer ist das nicht. Das kriegst du, glaube ich, hin. Das schaffst du auf jeden Fall. Dein grosser Pfau, dein Hühner-Avatar oder so ist dann schon der krasseste. Dein grosser Pfau-Avatar? Ja. Ja, das wird toll. Ich bin jetzt Rennfahrer, also cooler wird's nicht mehr. Du mit deinem Helm und meinem V-und-Schweif.
Ja, ich bin einfach so ein Cooler mit so einem coolen Helm. Und dann fährst du die Formel-1-Strecken lang. Weiche Formel-1-Strecken, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, habe ich Lust auf was Neues, aber ich fühle mich noch nicht so wohl, weil ich habe mir schon gedacht, eigentlich ist schon Sport die beste Unterhaltung. Ich habe ja mein ganzes Leben eigentlich eher auf Sport heruntergeschaut, so die Fussball-Prols und früher dann so Handball und ja Borussia und ich denke mir das ist einfach dumm und albern und es ist einfach Quatsch so dieser Lokalpatriotismus, das ist alles irgendwie so mir zuwider, ich schaue Filme, Theater in eine andere Welt, da irgendwie humanistisches Ideal, wir sind alle gleich, wir versetzen uns in andere hinein, aber letzten Endes, denke ich mir, ist Sport schon eine gute Unterhaltung, weil es hört halt nie auf, es geht halt immer weiter. Deine Lieblingsserie kann abgesetzt werden, dein Film ist irgendwann zu Ende, Herr der Ringe, die Reihe ist durch, Sport geht jedes Jahr weiter und es wird ja jedes Jahr besser, weil du lernst die Leute kennen, du hast die Geschichte, oh der hat jetzt immer verloren, der hat letztes Jahr Jahr knapp verloren, jetzt schafft, versucht das nochmal oder so. Eigentlich ist nicht Sport die bessere Unterhaltung. Oh ja, da würde ich sagen, nein, für mich nicht. Ich weiß es nicht, das Problem ist, man kann da nicht so mal so reinschnuppern, weil ich glaube, Sport ist ein Hobby, das wird besser, je mehr Zeit man investiert. Am Anfang checkst du erst mal gar nichts. Es wird auch dann cooler, also je mehr du dich auskennst und je mehr man dann auch damit investiert. Aber man kann schlecht mal testen. Man kann schlecht testen zum Beispiel. Also je mehr du damit noch machst. Wetten würde ich jetzt nicht einsteigen. Ich will jetzt nicht, keine Werbung dafür machen, aber wenn ein Typ einfach direkt kippt. Nee, nee, ich will nur sagen. Und guck mal, das widert mich so an an Sport, dass dann direkt bist du in so einem Wettlokal, dann irgendwie Kaffee, Wodka oder so. Nee, was ich damit sagen will, ist ja, je mehr man damit macht, desto mehr ist man auch noch investiert. Und ich glaube auch, dass es bei vielen Leuten eben nicht Lokalpatriotismus ist, sondern die Zugehörigkeit zu einem Team führt halt dazu, dass man viel mehr Spaß hat beim Gucken. Absolut, es ist ja auch total schlau. Genau. Und gehst du da hin, wenn die spielen, dann fährst du da hin, dann ist es so ein Event und dann passiert was und ein gemeinsames Erlebnis. Und du kannst dich identifizieren, weißt dann auch mehr darüber. Und beim Film ist es ja auch so, dass du dir einen rauspickst, eine, die wohl mitgehst und relaten kannst. Ich habe jetzt für mich das Experiment gestartet, ich versuche jetzt. Gebt Sport eine Chance. Ja, ich gebe Sport eine Chance. Welchem Sport? Golf? Ich habe mir erst lange Baseball angeguckt, nicht gerafft, dann habe ich Golf angeschaut, nicht verstanden und jetzt bin ich bei der Formel 1 angekommen. Und ich habe tatsächlich gestern mein erstes Formel 1-Rennen angeschaut und ich weiß, es passt nicht zu mir und ich fühle mich da auch irgendwie fremd. Ich fremde da total. Ich verstehe das nicht. Ich verstehe die Faszination nicht. Aber vielleicht muss ich es mir auch einfach anzwingen. Vielleicht muss ich es mir auch einfach anzwingen. So Brokkoli schmeckt auch beim ersten Mal nicht gut, aber du musst es dir runterzwängen, weil es gesund ist. Aber hast du gar keinen Spaß dabei? Naja, doch, aber es ist so... Hast du schon Weizen dabei aufgemacht? Ich kann mir das alles nicht vorstellen.. Du hast es geguckt, hast es auf deinem Schreibtischstuhl geguckt? Ich hatte meine Füsse auf den Pedalen und habe immer gedacht, jetzt komm, gib Gast, Kollege, jetzt musst du Gast geben. Aber hast du mitgefiebert, hast du dir einen Pfarrer ausgesucht, mit dem du mitfieberst? Ja, ein bisschen schon. Mit wem hast du mitgefiebert? Ja, ich bin ja schon so Haars-Fan, so ein bisschen, muss ich sagen. Wintersteiner hat es dir angetan. Ja, nein, ich will will jetzt auch gar nichts in den Detail gehen, weil ich merke schon, wie ich direkt schon alle langweile, wie ich auch mich selber langweile, weil es ist einfach saulangweilig. Dann machst du 20 Podcast-Urbefolgen von mir zu Nieder. Ich probiere es jetzt einfach mal. Ich werde wahrscheinlich in ein paar Wochen wieder sagen, ich habe aufgegeben, ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Aber letztendlich war irgendwie mit Serien, ich komme einfach auch nicht mehr weiter, ich habe irgendwie keine Ahnung, es ist ja so, vielleicht tue ich mir auch nicht mehr so leicht, Spaß zu haben, abzuschalten. Bei Serien, ich gucke immer wieder, habe andere Tabs offen und so und denke mir immer so, soll ich mir die was anderes angucken? Ich glaube, ich verliere so die Fähigkeit, Spaß zu haben und will die zurück. Vielleicht muss man die auch einfach im Erwachsenenalter ab einem gewissen Punkt einfach loslassen und man ist dann halt eher
bei Steuer und Haushalt und Wand
und Haustapete und so.
Weil ich schaue so Freunde auf so einem Umfeld
von mir an, die haben auch keinen
Spaß im klassischen Sinne.
Die sagen, ja, wir suchen jetzt
eine Wohnung, Tapete
und Garten, da müssen wir jetzt gucken,
wie das ist mit dem Zaun und so. Ich denke mir so,
die reden nie über so Spaß. Und ich denke mir, vielleicht ist Spaß auch irgendwann einfach durch. Ist überholt. Ja, vielleicht ist es einfach irgendwann durch. So und dann vielleicht versuche ich, mich an einem Konzept festzuklammern. Ich glaube, viele Leute haben Spaß, ein Leben zu spielen. Ja, so Sims im echten Leben. Ja, genau. Das ist ja genau das, was ich gerade meinte. Sie spielen die Roleplay einer Familie. Weil das ist natürlich vorgelebt. Alle wachsen in so was auf. Also ich glaube, alle wachsen mit der Vorstellung einer heilen Familie auf. Und ich glaube, dass beide Jobs, beide ziehen dann, also viele Freunde von mir ziehen jetzt zusammen wieder in mein Heimatdorf. Oh ja. Ziehen dann da in diese Häuser und Doppelhaushälften, in denen wir alle gewohnt haben. Und das ist total spannend zu beobachten. Ich glaube, und das sind auch die Leute, die ich da jetzt gerade rein interpretiert habe, bei deinem, da ist kein Spaß, kein Thema mehr. Das ist, finde ich, greift jetzt zu weit, weil die sind die Leute, die in Escape Rooms gehen und die Feuermelder ab. Und die schauen ja auch Formel 1. Also das sind dann eher so die Leute. Formel 1 schauen und die Feuermelder abschrauben, weil die da drinnen den Schlüssel von Barbossa vermuten. Ja, ja. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, die Role-Play-Familie. Ja. Weil erstrebenswert, was wollen wir da alle? Sicherheit, überleben, bla bla bla, im Kern, kollektives Unterbewusstsein ist, glaube ich, das das Ziel. Und dann, zack, die erste Erinnerung ist die einer heilen Familie, wird vorgelebt aus Filmen, Kultur, und dann ist es sozusagen das zu spielen. Und dass das größte Problem dann gerade der Zaun ist draußen oder der Nachbar, der seine Weidenkätzchen über die Grenze hat wachsen lassen,
ist dann das größte Problem.
Ich glaube, ich habe den Punkt verpasst,
wo man an so mondänen Sachen Spaß hat.
So, welche Farbe für die Wand ist mir vollkommen egal,
welche Türklinke ist mir vollkommen egal,
könnte mir nicht egaler sein.
Ich glaube, da habe ich den Punkt verpasst,
vielleicht muss ich mal mehr im Baumärkten.
Das ist alles, ja, finde ich gut,
aber das ist mir alles total wichtig.
Und ich habe auch noch Lust auf Spaß. Genau, du hast den Punkt, du hast es geschafft. Mir ist es einfach egal. Nee, aber mir ist es auch viel egal, aber also so Wohnungsästhetik oder so Interior Design, würde ich es mal behaupten, ist es auch kein Hobby von mir. Es macht mir sehr viel Spaß, aber auch dieses Konzept des Hobbys,
da denke ich letzter Zeit
drüber nach.
Ab wann ist es ein Hobby,
ich glaube,
Leute, man beschäftigt sich ja eher weniger mit Hobbys,
vielleicht in der Rente wieder, ich weiß es nicht.
Dir spaßbereitende,
zeitschluckende Aktivitäten,
das ist meine Definition von Hobbys.
Ich habe aktuell wieder ein Projekt, weil ich habe ein Problem, und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, im Supermarkt gibt es ja, also ist das ein bisschen speziell, aber vielleicht weißt du, was ich meine. Es gibt im Supermarkt ja so Rabattaktionsprodukte, zum Beispiel im Supermarkt, ich liebe ja zweistöckige Supermärkte mit so einer, Rolltreppe ist nicht das richtige Wort, weil es keine Treppe, aber so eine
Fließband. Laufband.
Und das ist das so geil, weil
die Wägen, wenn du einen Wagen hast,
die haken sich so ein und
niemand weiß, wie das geht.
Aber guck mal, das sind die kleinen
Freuden des Alltags, die wir jetzt Erwachsenen,
die wir mit Vierziger
genießen können, wie der
Einkaufswagen sich so verkeilt. Und da ist ja immer in dem Zwischenraum ist ja diese Impulsiv-Quengelware, ne? Ja. So, auch bei Baumärkten gibt es das manchmal, wenn du so hoch fährst. Und mir ist es, und eigentlich ist es ja ein Zeichen der Schwäche, wenn man da was rausnimmt. Weil es ist ja Quengelware, das sind ja Dinge, die man nicht braucht und deswegen ist mir das immer ein bisschen unangenehm, daraus Sachen zu nehmen, weil es gibt mittlerweile ein Produkt, das ich explizit kaufen möchte, für das ich in den Supermarkt gehe, was es nur da gibt. Und ich fühl mich immer so schlecht, weil du stehst da hinter dir, stehen Leute vorne, stehen alle gucken so gelangweilt und ich bin dann der, der so reingreift und ich fühle alle, ich fühle mich so, die Gedankenblasen kann ich lesen, so ach Gott, so ein Impuls, so ich will ein Schwacher, der sich da so die Mini-Brownies in so einer Tüte, so diese Biskuit-Rollen, so du bist da gequengelt wie in der Kasse, Mama, Mama, kann ich noch ein Dupe noch? Ein kleines Baby, was nicht seine Impulse zurückhalten kann. Ja, er kann seine Begierde nicht kontrollieren. Schau dir diesen Schwächling an. Guck ihn dir an. Guck dir dieses massiv übergewichtige vierjährige Kind an, wie es sich direkt wieder die nächsten Brownies ins Gesicht stoppen will. Er ist so pathetic, aber du bist zu hot. Du bist eiskalt. Ich liebe dich, weil du machst das nie. Du wirst es nie machen. Schatz, wir fahren an diesen Quengelwaren vorbei. Ich will dich jetzt gleich hier. Wir brauchen das nicht. Ich will dich jetzt gleich hier. Ich brauche nur dich an. Ich brauche nur dich an. Du bist meine Impulse. Du bist die Bessere. Ich brauche dich. Ja, komm her. Schau dir diesen Vollidioten an. Dann geilen sich Leute an sich auf, weil sie dich so pathetic finden. Genau. Weil sie dich so unangenehm finden. Aber manchmal, und dann denke ich mir so, ich bin gerade der, durch den sich alle anderen gut fühlen. Ich brauche das nicht. Ich bin nicht so abhängig. Nein, da hast du nicht das Gefühl, du nimmst ihn nicht. Du nimmst dann nicht das Produkt. Du bist wie ich und würdest es dann einfach nicht kaufen. Und was ich letzten Endes mache, ist, ich fahre diese Treppe locker sieben, acht Mal hoch und runter, um genau den Moment abzupassen, wo ganz wenig andere auch auf der Treppe sind, wo ich dann so mal so nebenbei, und ich lehne mich dann auch so ganz weit übers Geländer so, und dann versuche ich so mit dem... Aber es ist wie so, ich verstehe es, es ist genau wie für Leute, die das nicht kennen, so angenommen, ihr braucht ein Produkt, und genau dieses Produkt hat dann so einen Werbestand im Supermarkt, so eine Rabattaktion oder sowas. Oder ist gerade so massiv runtergesetzt und so alle Sale-runtergesetzt-Zeichen gehen dann so da rauf. Und ihr seht so aus wie so Konsumopfer, die genau da rauf jetzt reinfallen. Und weil es diesen Stand da jetzt gibt, dann da hingehen und was haben wir denn hier? Wie so Leute, die so jeden Tag in den Supermarkt gehen und so beeindruckt sind von diesem Neuen. Ich bin einfach impulsgeleitet, vor allem man baut den Supermarkt ja so, dass man darauf zugeführt wird. Und seitdem ich weiß, wie Supermärkte gebaut werden, habe ich so diesen inneren Trotz in mir, so nicht denen zum Opfer zu fallen. Man kennt das ja so, nein, ich kaufe nicht die auf Augenhöhe, ich kaufe nicht die Besonderprodukte, ich kaufe nicht das Gemüse, sondern ich kaufe nur meine Billigchips den ganzen Tag und Billig-Erdnuss-Butter. und dann schiebe ich meine Billigchips in die Billig-Erdnuss-Butter rein und stopfe mir das voll einfach, weil ich es kann, weil ich nicht das mache, was du wolltest. Nimm das, nimm das, nimm das, nimm das Rewe, ich kaufe andere Produkte bei dir. Es ist furchtbar und es ist immer wieder, ich fahre hundertmal hoch und runter und versuche irgendwie da ranzukommen. Und ich habe echt schon überlegt, ob ich so einen Slinky, so einen Gummigreifarm haben soll, der da so da einmal reingeht. Das ist schwierig. Du musst was finden. Vielleicht schaust du so Slide-of-Hand-Videos von so sauberen mal anschauen. Ja, oder ich vermittle den Eindruck, dass ich genau danach suche. Ich habe mir nämlich auch schon überlegt, ob ich es auf einem Handy so tun soll, als hätte ich eine Einkaufsliste und ich gucke so, ah, da haben wir es. So, damit. Wie du das spielst, mit so einem ARD-Vorabendgesicht. Ah, der kommt, oh, ah, Schatz, Schatz, brauchen wir nicht noch die Malteser? Ah, hier sind sie ja direkt, da nehme ich eine Packung. Ich wäre so ein Arschloch, wenn ich mit dir unterwegs wäre und du würdest dann da, wir schieben dann unseren Einkaufswagen durch die Gegend und du kaufst dann diese Quengelware in der Mitte, würde ich ganz laut sagen, mit dir kann man auch wirklich nirgendwo vorbeigehen. Oh Gott. Schrecklich, aber ich verstehe es genau. Aber, nee, Supermärkte kann ich gar nicht, ich hasse Supermärkte inzwischen. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist bei mir, aber ich gehe auch noch super selten, oft dann irgendwie nach dem Sport mit Kopfhörern noch ungeduscht auf dem Weg nach Hause, nach dem Sport gehe ich dann ganz schnell durch den Supermarkt, hole mir dann ein paar Sachen und gehe dann wieder nach Hause, will mir niemanden sehen, niemanden angucken, keinen Blickkontakt und einfach schnell, schnell nach Hause. Und dann gehe ich dann noch in die Selbstkasse, Selbstbedienungskasse. Oh, das ist das Beste. Das ist das Beste, finde ich ganz toll, auch wenn es leer ist bei der Kasse. Warte ich dann lieber noch kompliziert. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann guckt der Typ von der Kasse mich an, sie kann auch hierhin kommen und ich sage, nein, nein, ich möchte, dass sie, nein, ich möchte, dass sie durch Maschinen ersetzt werden. Entschuldigung. Wie war das? Nein, ich möchte, dass Sie durch Maschinen ersetzt werden. Ich möchte, dass Sie konkret, Sie konkret ausgetauscht werden durch eine Maschine. Ich will lieber, ich würde lieber von einer Maschine sehr langsam bedient werden, als von Ihnen sehr schnell. Nein, nein, nein, von Ihnen. Das ist doppelt der Preis beim Checkout, ne? Ich würde Geld dafür bezahlen, damit ich selbst Checkout machen kann.
Ich will lieber, ich will, dass sie und ihre ganze Familie keinen Job bekommen mehr auf Lebenszeit, damit ich da an diese, damit niemandem reden muss, weil ich bin leicht, leicht introvertiert. Aber es ist wirklich das Beste, ich liebe das. Eine Freundin hat mich gesehen, wie ich durch diesen Supermarkt gegangen bin, in diesem nach dem Sport Tempo Speedrun durch den Supermarkt. Und sie hat gesagt, es ist so unangenehm, wie du durch diesen Supermarkt schnaufst. Turns out. Du schnaufst? Ich schnaufe. Du hast die Noise-Canceling im Kopf. Ich hab meine Noise-Canceling-Airpods drin. Und augenscheinlich, und das ist mir schon mal damals passiert,
als wir noch diese dicken Over-Ears hatten, die wir alle bei guter Arbeit getragen haben, ich hab ja jetzt die In-Ears und ich dachte, ich hab's abgelegt dadurch. Aber anscheinend vergesse ich, wie man richtig atmet. Und wenn ich meinen Atem nicht mehr höre, fang ich an so rumzuschnaufen. Okay, aber das geht ja fast schon ins Grunde rein.
Aber ich will jetzt, und, nee, nee, das habe ich jetzt so gemacht, ich weiß nicht, wie ich dann atme.
Ich atme wohl sehr schnaufend laut und ich dachte ja immer, ich will hier nicht wahrgenommen werden,
ich möchte einfach nur sehr schnell durch diesen Supermarkt anonym und dann wieder nach Hause.
Aber was das dazu geführt hat, dass ich wahnsinnig aufmerksamkeitshaschend, schnaufend durch diesen Supermarkt rende. Sie meinte, plötzlich lief so eine grosse Gestalt, schnaufend schnell an ihr vorbei. Sie kam, obwohl sie mich erkannt hat, gar nicht zu dem Moment, mich mehr berüchen zu können. Was für ein Voll-Stefan? Aber ich fand es gut, mal jetzt zu hören. Das ist wie, man muss hören, dass man so Basilikum inzwischen den Zähnen hat. Du musst manchmal auch den Brief ins Haus bekommen, wo ein Foto von dir ist, wie du in so eine Radarfalle gerätst, dass du erst mal merkst, wie sehe ich eigentlich aus beim Autofahren? Was ist das für ein Gesichtsausdruck? Warum ist der Mund offen? Ja, weil ich singe, weil ich laut schelke, schel Shake it off mitsinge. Bei mir ist entweder Wut, so Road Rage oder Happys Musical Gesicht. Ja, total, es gibt nur zwei Stufen davon. Nee, nee, alles dazwischen existiert nicht. Existiert nicht. Hast du Angst, Tauben zu überfahren im Auto? Ja. Wirklich, weil ich sehe immer oft Tauben vor mir auf der Strasse und denke mir, ist das jetzt meine Aufgabe? Oder ich denke mir immer so, niemand macht Tauben was vor. So Tauben sind die absoluten Kenner der Stadt, die kennen jeden Winkel, du musst keine Rücksicht auf Tauben nehmen. Laut Seinfeld, we have a deal. Ja, genau. We have a deal. Ja. Und dann hat George mal irgendwann, glaube ich, eine Taube angefahren Oder Jerry hat dann ganz laut geschrien, I thought we had a deal! I thought we had a deal! Ja! Weil man denkt, unser Deal ist, bei euch ist er das eine Tier, was man ignorieren kann. Genau. Man fährt einfach schnell drauf zu. Genau. Wir ignorieren euch, dafür bringen wir euch auch nicht um. Ihr dürft mit uns in der Stadt leben, aber dafür ignorieren wir uns gegenseitig. Wir fahren nicht um euch rum. Tauben sind eigentlich der perfekte Mitbewohner. Die sind zwar da, aber die gehen sofort aus dem Weg und die knabbern dann hier und da. Ganz kurz, ich will nur kurz das Korn nehmen. Ja, okay. Kurzes Maiskorn. Oh, dann bin ich weg. Sofort. Und wenn du einen Schritt zu nah kommst, oh, genau, morgen, dann später, dann später, dann heute Abend, dann heute Abend. Du brauchst deinen Space und ich weiss das. Okay, alles klar, dann komme ich heute Abend nochmal. Du brauchst deinen Space und ich weiss das. Ich bin Taube, alles klar. Gut, schau, schau, weg. Luft ausgelökt. Mit so einem Nebel, so einer Nebelkugel, die man vom Boden wirken. Ich bin weg. Es ist fantastisch. Ich habe auch diese Woche mich ein bisschen, ich habe Recherche betrieben für einen Tweet, der es dann doch nicht geworden ist. Und zwar, ich habe mich auseinandergesetzt mit der Friedenstaube. Weil ich wollte wissen, warum ist gerade die Taube das Zeichen für Frieden? Ist es nicht das lahmste Tier? Ein dreckigstes Ekeltier, die Ratte der Lüfte. Die Prämisse des Tweets sollte so ein bisschen sein, wäre Frieden nicht beliebter, wenn es ein cooleres Tier hätte als Logo, so. Ist es dann nicht geworden, aber ich habe ein bisschen recherchiert zur Friedenstaube, ganz fantastisch.
May I say solider Tweet? Vielen Dank, dass du die Erwägung gezogen hast. Ja, also stellt sich raus, es geht natürlich zurück auf Noah mal wieder, wo ja diese Taube irgendwann zurückkam mit dem Olivenzweig im Mund und einen Baum gefunden hat. So boring, super boring, super langweilig, langweilig. So, was ich aber fantastisch fand, auf dem Wikipedia-Eintrag von Friedenstaube steht ein ganz, ganz grossartiger Satz. Und dieser Satz ist also ein Satz wirklich für die Götter. Hier heißt es nämlich dann der dritte Satz, heißt es, wird als Friedenstaube bezeichnet, jetzt der Satz. Das Symbol der Friedenstaube hat in der Strassentaube, die in schätzungsweise 2000 Kämpfe im Jahr verwickelt ist, keine verhaltensbiologische Entsprechung. Das ist so ein geiler Satz. Wie abgefuckt muss man als Tier sein, dass man egal für welches Logo so schnell auf die Ersatzbank gesetzt wird, also so wahnsinnig schnell Distanzierung. Und dass explizit erwähnt werden muss, dass dein Verhalten nicht dem Symbol entspricht. Das Symbol der Friedenstaube hat in der Strassentaube, die in schätzungsweise 2000 Kämpfe im Jahr verwickelt ist, keine verhaltensbiologische Entsprechung. Nachgeforscht.
Gute Frage. Und ich dachte mir,
was soll das heißen? Taubenforscher.
Schätzungsweise
zweitausend Kämpfe.
Also das ist so
vage. Vor allem also
pro Taube oder
alle Tauben? Ne, ne, pro Taube.
Zweitausend im Jahr.
Das sind sechs am Tag. Fünf am Tag. 2000? 2000 ist einfach lächerlich. Aber es ist auch zu gerade, die Zahl. Und dann habe ich recherchiert, was ist die Quelle dafür, bin auf einen Artikel gekommen. 5,6 am Tag. Ja, 5,6 am Tag. Wie viele Tage hat 65? Und dann bin ich auf einen Artikel gestossen von Planet Wissen, wo es einfach nur heißt, untereinander gehen die Tauben nämlich häufig aggressiv auseinander los. Eine Strassentaube wird schätzungsweise in 2000 Kämpfe pro Jahr verwickelt. Ich finde, das Wort Schätzungsweise leistet hier eine Menge Arbeit, weil was heißt denn Schätzungsweise 2000 Kämpfe? Pi mal Daum, was sollst du mal unterschreiben, Pi mal Daum. Aber wer schätzt sowas? Also sagst du, also Wahnsinn, ich meine, ich stell mir so einen Typen vor mit so einem Klick-Ding. Ja, der hat eine Woche, der hat eine Taube eine Woche lang beobachtet und hat das dann hochgerechnet aufs Jahr. Wollte ich gerade nämlich auch vorschlagen, aber das glaube ich geht nicht, weil angenommen der Dezember ist der Friedensmonat oder sowas, oder es ist zu kalt zum oder es ist Brutzeit, es ist zu kalt zum Kämpfen oder sowas, deswegen glaube ich geht das nicht. Ich glaube, oder mit einer Zahl da landet, wo sie jetzt steht. Jetzt würde ich dich bitten, mal kurz bei Wikipedia in die Belege zu gehen. Genau da war ich gerade, da Oder den Satz zu löschen. Da gibt es den Artikel.
Ich weiß nicht, also wie gesagt,
Katrin Lankers schreibt in Planet Wissen
einen Artikel über Tauben und nennt dort diese Zahl 2000.
Und das ist der Beleg für Wikipedia.
Korrekt.
Dann würde ich den Satz jetzt löschen.
So kommen wir nicht als Wissenschaft weiter.
Ja, man müsste halt wissen,
also der Artikel behauptet das einfach nochmal, aber die Quelle hat keine Quelle mehr. Es gibt eine Quelle in den Artikel, aber der Artikel selber hat keine Quellen mehr für diese 2000 Kämpfe. Das ist ja völlig okay, so funktioniert der Wissenschaft. Du brauchst halt einfach mal eine Quelle, die muss aber dann auch bitte die Forschungsweise dann darlegen. Und wenn die Quelle davon ist, dass eine Seite schreibt schätzungsweise, sorry, ist das keine verdammte das ist keine Darstellungsberechtigung in dem Wikipedia-Artikel. Ja, Katrin Lankers hat diese Zahl aufgestellt. Du kriegst die Rüge, du kriegst die Podcast-Ufo-Taube. Die erstmal alles aussagen kann. Warte mal, ich bin hier tatsächlich gerade auf katrinlankers.de Taubenforscherin, Ornithologin. Das ist Autorin, Kleine Wunder überall. Uh, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das die gleiche Katrin. Es gibt ja Katrin Lankers, gibt es ja wie Sand am Meer. Nicht, dass wir jetzt, aber ich schreibe mal, es gibt hier eine Kontaktadresse. Wie sie das erforscht hat.
Schreib mal kurz eine E-Mail.
Liebe Frau Lankers.
Es gibt ein Kontaktformular.
Genau.
Wir alle wissen, dass es einfach am Ende, sogar meine Handynummer muss ich da angeben.
Gibst du die an?
Ja, klar.
So, okay.
Sehr geehrte Frau Lankers.
Oder sollten wir sagen, Taubenforscherin Lankers.
Denn als solche werden sie... Ich finde es auch geil, dass man direkt wir schreibt. Oder sollten wir lieber sagen, sehr geehrte Frau Lankers, Gurgur. Oh, so weit würde ich nicht einstellen. Nee, so weit würde ich auch nicht einstellen. Mit Freude las ich ihren Artikel zum Thema Taube. Auf Planet Wissen. Auf Planet Wissen. Der ist doch von Ihnen, oder? Nee, würde ich gar nicht, würde ich sofort einfach annehmen. Darin schreiben Sie von 2000 Kämpfen. Kämpfen. Die Tauben jeden Tag. Pro Taube, pro Jahr. Und das alles in all caps, wie du gerade gesprochen hast. Alles in all caps. Pro Punkt. Taube. Punkt Jahr. Pro Punkt Jahr. In Klammern Ausrufezeichen. Sick, sick. Das wird sogar inzwischen bei Wikipedia als Beleg als Quelle geführt. Genau, um die Taube explizit, um die Friedenstaube explizit vom Tier loszulösen. Um real existierenden Tier... Explizit von der Friedenstaube zu differenzieren. Ich finde gut, dass alle E-Mail-Streits, die wir anfangen, immer mit Vögeln zu tun haben. Das Letzte war der WC-Entestreit, der WC-Schwan, der WC-Entestreit. Es hat immer Vögel und auch Wurstbird. Was haben wir unterschwellig für einen Kampf gegen Vögel? Ich glaube, der Mensch kommt nicht drüber hinweg, dass Vögel fucking fliegen können und der Mensch halt nicht. Deswegen habe ich ja damals auch Wellensittich gehabt, aber die waren dann irgendwann auch so scheiße, dass ich die, ich mag auch Vögel einfach nicht. Nee, wirklich nicht. Die singen und sind laut und sind nervig. Nee, den Singsang mag ich wiederum. Kein Fan? Weiss ich nicht. Okay. Um die Taube exklusiv von der Friedenstaube zu differenzieren. Es hängt also alles an Ihnen. Gibt's diese Zahl auch in anderen ... Alles an Ihnen, Punkt, Semikolon. Okay, lass uns diesen sehr vage Satz. Sie ist Autorin, sie merkt auch, wenn die Satzzeichen nicht ganz sauber sind. Ja, das würde ich ja sagen. Ach, das ist auch als Machtmittel. Nee, gut, von dem denn habe ich mal gelernt, kann Semikolon kommen. Okay. Denn sie sind die einzige Quelle für diese Zahl. Deswegen die Frage zu ihrer Methode. Welche Forschungsmethode können sie die Forschungsmethode genau benennen? Können Sie uns die Forschungsmethode erläutern, durch die diese Zahl beste Grösse? Andernfalls müssten wir Sie bitten, den Satz zu löschen. Den Satz, den Wikipedia-Eintrag zu ändern oder ihr Planet-Wissen-Beitrag gründlich zu säubern. Wir Sie bitten, den Fakten neutral zu halten, den Wikipedia-Titel zu editieren und oder und oder und oder und ihren Artikel was hast du gesagt fakten neutral zu überarbeiten fakten neutral zu halten. Was soll das bedeuten, faktenneutral? Also keine Fakten. Nee, ich dachte, das heißt lediglich auf Fakten basierend neutral zu sein. Aber faktenneutral zu halten. Das ist schon Unsinn. Beste Grüße, Familie Sünner aus dem sonnigen Köln. Winkend, nee, war auch Winkend, komm mal. Familie Sünner aus dem sonnigen, aus dem regnerischen Köln und dann traurigen Smile. Aus dem regnerischen Köln, trauriger Smile. Aber jetzt musst du oben Florentinwill.icloud. Ach so, Florentin Sünner kann ich ja angeben. Also, sehr geehrte Frau Lankers, mit Freude las ich ihren Artikel zum Thema Taube auf Planetwissen.
Darin schreiben sie von 2000 Kämpfen pro Taube pro Jahr, Ausrufezeichen.
Das wird sogar inzwischen bei Wikipedia als Quelle geführt, um die Taube explizit von der Friedenstaube zu differenzieren.
Es hängt also alles an ihnen, Semikolon, denn sie sind die einzige Quelle für diese Zahl. Können Sie das nicht mehr so ein, was Sie nicht mehr so ein, was Sie nicht mehr so ein, was Sie nicht mehr so ein, was Sie Ihren Artikel faktenneutral zu halten. Winkend Familie Sünner aus dem regnerischen Köln. Okay, I am a human? Aus dem regnerischen Köln. Es ist aber, ich glaube, das ist gut am Ende, um sich nochmal zu verbrüdern. Es ist ganz wichtig. Erstmal wirklich ein harscher Ton, dann aber Familie Sünner aus dem regnerischen Köln. Schade. Uns geht es auch nicht so viel. Wie ich das lese, ich würde es lesen als, ah, da hat sich eine Familie, da hat irgendwie eine Familie mit zwei neugierigen, neugierigen Kindern. Ja. Und die neugierigen Kindern haben das gesehen und dann irgendwie der Vater hat das so als Projekt jetzt angenommen, erklären zu wollen. Genau. Und irgendwie nämlich das einigermaßen süss war, weil es ist so, als hätte er mit den Kindern dann diese Mail jetzt geschrieben an diese Frau, die sie ausfindig gemacht haben, weil die Kinder irgendwie neugierig bei einem Referat entgeckt haben, dass die Friedensdauer gar nicht so friedlich ist. Andere Idee, der Vater hat den Kindern bei der Hausaufgabe geholfen und die Kinder haben eine Sechs bekommen. Und der Vater versucht jetzt irgendwie seine Forschung zu retten, weil die haben eine Sechs bekommen wegen unzureichender Quellenlage. Und der Vater hat denen aber versichert, dass das schon so geht, Wikipedia reicht, und jetzt muss er nochmal ... Vater muss zurückrudern. Oder Vater ist ja arbeitslos, jetzt geworden, hat sehr viel Zeit plötzlich, die Mutter sagt, jetzt besucht ihr mal ein Hobby oder sowas, aber keine Ahnung, du sitzt die ganze Zeit nur und schreibst komische Mails an Leute. Also eines von diesen Szenarien will zutreffen, denkt die wahrscheinlich. Aber wie oft das schon passiert ist, die Eltern helfen dem Kind beim Vortrag und dann kriegt sie sechs, war alles falsch. Ich habe mal, ich weiß noch genau, damals hat unsere Grundschullehrerin im Sachunterricht dann irgendwann so eine grosse Mindmap zu Elektrizität gemacht. Okay. Und ich habe da aufgezeigt und relativ früh gesagt, AC sozusagen. Früh gesagt ACDC, habe ich gesagt. Also Gleichstrom, Wechselstrom. Und sie hat gesagt, nein, das ist eine Band. War ich abgewatscht. Ich war einfach so, plötzlich war ich im Abseits. In der Pause wurde nicht mehr mit mir gesprochen. Die Herde hat mich erstossen. Plötzlich war ich aussässiger. Pff, sagt er eine Band. Er sagt eine Band. Und das ist für Kinder oft schon, reicht das schon aus. Es wirkt erst mal sehr dumm. Wenn man sagt, was habt ihr zu Strom? Guns in Roses. Revolverheld. Ich liebe Revolverheld. Nein, Stefan, das ist ja eine Band. Kinder lachen leicht. Verstehen auch nicht, was falsch gelaufen ist, aber Kinder merken die Reaktion von der Lehrerin,
merken, Stefan ist mobbar, aussätzlich.
Die Euphorie des Kindes passt nicht zur Reaktion des Erwachsenen.
Stefan meldet sich, schnippt, sagt ACDC und dann ist erst mal Stille im Raum.
Und schon war ich im Abseits.
Die Leute lösten sich von mir.
Ich stand alleine mit meiner Kaba, stand ich draußen an der Schaukel und überlegte meine nächsten Schritte. Wie konnte ich das Vertrauen der Männer Mitschülerinnen und Mitschüler zurückgewinnen? Hatte ich doch eigentlich nichts als die Wahrheit, die Wahrheit und nichts als die Wahrheit gesprochen? Oder und die Wahrheit gesprochen. Dabei sah ich sie, meine Mitschülerinnen und Mitschüler, kleine Infanten. Sie wussten nicht, was passiert war. Sie bemerkten die Reaktion der Lehrerin und schon war ich ein Aussätziger. Ihre zarten Gesichter zu hässlichen Fratzen verzerrt, schauten sie mich über ihre kleinen Schultern an, kichernd, zeigend, lachend. Lachend, kleine Kreisel gegeneinander antreten zu lassen. Beyblade nannten sie das. Für mich war es einfach nur infantiler Kinderunfug. Doch egal, wer bei diesem Kampf gewann, ich verlor. Der Intellekt und ich verloren. Und die Schwerkraft. Das gyrokopische Prinzip und ich, wir verloren. Die Zentrifugalkraft ist eine Scheinkraft, aber das ist der Nombran der erwähnt. Und so ging ich nach Hause, um meine nächsten Schritte sorgfältig zu überlegen. Jetzt wieder alles war und so saß ich dann zu Hause und habe gesagt, wie kriege ich das jetzt hin? Gleichstrom, Wechselstrom. Ich bin zu meinem Vater gegangen. Mein Vater ist ironischerweise Elektriker. Oder nicht, oder vielleicht gerade nicht. Vielleicht auch gerade nicht. Deswegen wusstest du zu viel. Und deswegen war das für mich ein Riesenschmach, was da gerade passiert war. Als Elektrikers Sohn, das geht nicht. Ich kam blass nach Hause und er hat gesagt, mein Sohn, mein Elektrikers Sohn. Ist bei dir die Sicherung rausgeflogen? Was ist passiert? Die sind wohl die Sicherung rausgeflogen. Warum machst du denn diese Farbe? Die stehen die Haare zu Berge.
Da habe ich gesagt, es ist eine schlimme Sache passiert.
Ich habe noch sehr viel Widerstand getroffen.
Aber wie viel Widerstand? Acht Ohm.
So, dann das Gespräch, Gespräch, Gespräch, Gespräch.
Und herauskam, ich hatte wie immer Recht, die Lehrerin, die dumme Nuss, Unrecht.
Und dann bekam ich, mein Vater hat so eine riesen Lexikon hatten wir zu Hause. Lächerlich, groß. Es passte nicht in meinen Rucksack. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr dumme Nuss, Unrecht. Und dann bekam ich, mein Vater hat so ein riesen Lexikon hatten wir zu Hause, lächerlich groß. Es passte nicht in meinen Rucksack, das weiß ich noch. Es war sehr gross, war so, was ist das, eins grösser als die nach vier, die nach drei. Ja, das ist eine kleinere Zahl nehmen für etwas Größeres. Brillant! Anderes Thema, nicht abschweifen. Okay, sorry, ich bin in einem Ramp. Nicht zu viele Semikolons. Aber du gibst mir recht.
Ja, absolut.
Und dann habe ich diesen grossen, so dirke Weltatlas,
Grösse eines Lexikons gehabt,
aber mit so einer dicke von so, sagen wir mal, so einer Banane.
Also nee, wenn man die aufstellt.
What, einer aufrechten Banane?
Richtig grosses, dickes Ding.
Es war so lustig, es war eher so ein Gag.
Nein, nicht so.
So wie eine kleine Banane. Eine Cola-Dose. Eine Cola-Dose. Okay. Super, super dick. Und das musste ich in meinen Armen tragen, wie das die Mädchen aus Highschool-Filmen machen immer, die dann immer umgerempelt werden. So habe ich dann dieses große, anders konnte ich es nicht tragen, mit meinem kleinen Ärmchen, dieses großes Atlas mit in die Schule gebracht. Und die Lehrerin war so genervt, dass ich dann plötzlich mal wieder, es ist auch schon mal vollkommen davor. Es war schon die nächste Stunde, nächstes Thema, Sexualkunde. Sexualkunde. Und ich sag, sorry, ganz kurz, dann habe ich diesen grossen Atlas, habe dann so ein Post-it reingemacht, wo dann Gleichstrom, Wechselstrom stand, AC-DC, Alternate ... Current? Ja. Und das andere, Direct Current. Und habe ich ihr dann erklärt und war sie zufrieden. Ich hab keine Note bekommen oder so was. Es war nur dieses ... Ich wollte ihr zeigen, dass ich auch Recht hatte. Und die Gunst meiner Klassenkameraden zurückgebracht. Wurdest du wieder in die Gemeinschaft aufgenommen? Ich wurde wieder in die gleiche. Also man hat dann wirklich die Arme wieder geöffnet und gesagt, okay, wir nehmen das Mobben zurück, jetzt bist du wieder Teil der Gruppe. Und nun flog auch mein Beyblade wieder durch die Lüfte, um zu gewinnen. Doch was hatte ich davon? Ich hatte Recht, aber keine Freunde mehr. Sehr schön, eine sehr schöne Geschichte auf jeden Fall, Stefan. Ich finde es auch schön, also hast du denn das Gefühl, du hast durch deinen familien Hintergrund mehr Durchblick bei Strom, weil ich raff Strom so überhaupt gar nicht, so null. Man, also man müsste ja meinen, dass die Schalter auch, wenn man ein Vater hat, der Elektriker ist, sinnvoll, irgendwie alles cool ist. Aber man hat so gimmicky Dinge, wie zum Beispiel unser Flur damals. Unser Flur, in den man reinkam am Anfang, hatte eine Bewegungsmelder, dass immer wenn man durchging, ging der an. Aber es ist super nervig, aus vielen Gründen, man macht sich dann irgendwie, man zieht sich was an oder sowas und guckt, wie man mit dem Spiegel aussieht im Flur, da war auch so unsere Garderobe und dann zack geht das Licht aus. Da musst du erst wieder mit den Händenänden hin. Ja, da muss man dann, wie oft alle Familienmitglieder wedelnd im Flur standen. Und dann war der auch nicht nur so halbgeil, weil er irgendwie von der Arbeit umsonst mitbekommt. So ein Sonntagsmodell. Alles scheiße, Montagsmodell. Oder war es das Schlechte? Was der schlechte Griff noch nie gehört. Naja, das Modell war nicht so geil. Oder wir hatten dann so einen Kellerraum, der von allen Seiten, in denen man kam, Lichtschalter hatte. Aber die waren nicht, die überschreiben sich aber nicht. Sondern immer der letzte Klick zählt. Was aber dazu führt, es war auch mega merkwürdig, weil es hätten so drei Menschen in verschiedenen Ecken des Raums hätten ... Also das immer oben an und unten aus war, sondern das war immer anders. Alles willkürlich und man muss auch zweimal drücken, um den ersten zu überschreiben. Und dann, es war so kompliziert ist die Schaltung der Welt. Das ist Escape Room quasi schon in sich selbst. Genau, aber ich verstehe es natürlich aus einer Elektrikersicht total, mal fuck it, einfach mal Dinge zu machen. Aber es war eher so das Haus eines verrückten Professors. Der mit seiner Superkraft irgendwie nichts Cooles machen kann. Der ist Herr über Strom und Schaltung, aber so richtig, so eine Tesla-Spule und so, irgendwie was richtig Cooles kommt dann da noch nicht bei rum. Nein, nein, und deswegen überall Dimmschalter, alles weird. Es war wieder so alles ausprobiert, aber man denkt immer, da wo Elektriker, Väter oder Mütter am Start sind, hast du halt irgendwie keine Probleme. Nein, du hast die weirdesten Lampen mit den weirdesten Birnen, dann gehen die jetzt kaputt. Ich finde die nicht. Im Baumarkt, ich weiß nicht, was das für Birnen sein sollen, ob die jemals überhaupt verbaut. Ach, die wurden einmal für eine Woche, 1983 verbaut. Das ist so ein neues Prototyp-Konzeptmodell. Und dein Vater hat gesagt, das ist die Zukunft, ich kaufe da jetzt eine ganze Kiste davon. Ja, irre, also dann, weil er halt dann so nahe...
Er ist zu sehr am Cutting-Edge, er ist zu sehr an der Innovation. Ich glaube, wenn du zu sehr dringend bist, ist auch so, so viele Leute regen sich ja auf über Pädagogeneltern, was ich auch verstehe. Ach so, das ist immer so der neuesten Pädagogenstil. Das weiß ich nicht, aber viele Leute, die Pädagogeneltern haben, haben leichte bis mittelschwere Probleme mit ihren Eltern. Und das kenne ich super viele. Und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht auch so ein bisschen dieses Elektriker-Vater-Problem ist. Menschen, die zu sehr im Thema sind, machen Weird Shit mit diesem Thema. Spannende Frage, ja, interessant. Ja, finde ich gut, wie so der Beruf der Eltern die Kindheit prägt. Können wir da eine neue Rubrik aufmachen? Ja. Was hatten eure Eltern
für wie die Berufe, die euer Leben beeinflusst haben?
Also musstet ihr ständig angeln gehen,
weil eure Eltern Köder
Wurmwürme waren?
Egal.
Weil eure Eltern Köder
für Weisse-Haie-Expeditionen waren.
Ich bin hauptberuflicher Köder.
Ich schmecke einfach sehr, sehr gut.
Es war immer die Angst, dass mein Vater mal irgendwann einen dieser Haiköder-Jobs nicht überlebt. Er wurde für so bei den Bahamas, für Touri. Genau, er musste immer ganz bluten, er musste immer das Wasser voll bluten, damit die Haie kamen. Er hatte das leckerste Blut der Karibik, hat man gesagt. Sein Job war es dann, für die Touristen die Haie anzulocken. Ja, bis zu diesem einen Donnerstag. Naja, egal. Wo er beim Bootsunglück. Wo er beim Rasenmäherunglück leider verstorben ist. Alle Haie kamen zur Beerdigung, um ihren Respekt zu zollen. Es war sehr furchteinflössend. Ist ein Tier was das Friedenstier, was das Friedensmacht? Ja, der Friedenshai? Finde ich gar nicht schlecht, der Friedenshai. Überlegt mal, vielleicht gibt es da bessere Tiere, haut mal was raus, ansonsten sehen wir uns in der nächsten Woche wieder, wenn es wieder heißt. Wir sehen uns gar nicht. Naja, wir sehen uns beide. Ja, den Rest hören wir nur. Ja, das stimmt, Dann hören wir uns nächste Woche. Okay, alles klar.
Das war gegen irgendetwas.
Schlechtere Räume reingebracht.
Haut rein, schöne Woche, macht's gut.
Wir heben ab, ciao.
Ciao sind...
The worst, literally.
Das war literally in the worst bird production.